Joe Biden's approval ratings are at an  all-time low of 28 percent 81 million  people voted for him 28 here's msnbc's  Chuck Todd  Biden's job approval rating sits at 44  in this final NBC News poll by the way  all-time low with Independence is  appropriating is just 28 okay sorry  sorry I should clarify that so it was 28  with Independence now again those  Independents those are the people that  sometimes go this way sometimes goes  sometimes go this way so that's what's  so interesting about this the people who  can move right now they've clearly had  it with the Democrats and again you just  have to think about what did people  actually do this in the in the last two  years people that that were frustrated  they left blue States and blue cities  they didn't nobody left Texas really  right nobody left Florida nobody left  Tennessee but blue generally blue people  did move to Red places and that tells  you something about a trend